اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي 15
فلسطينيه في مناطق متفرقه من الضفه
الغربيه والقدس المحتله وافاد نادي الاسير
الفلسطيني ان الاعتقالات تركزت في بلدات
وقراره الله والخليل والقدس حيث اقتحمت
قوات الاحتلال البلدات وداهمت المنازل
واقتاده المعتقلين الى معسكرات لتحقيق
معهم وقال جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان
قوته تعرضت لاطلاق نار في نابلس دون وقوعه
اصابات
عما اضراب شامل مدينه نابلس حدادا على
شهيدين محمد ابو كشك ومحمد حرز الله الذين
استشهد مساء امس متاثرين باصابتهما برصاص
قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وكان الشهيد محمد
ابو كشك البالغ من العمر 22 عاما قد اصيب
برصاص قوه الاحتلال في البطن خلال
اقتحامها الحيه الشرقي لمدينه نابلس
الليله الماضيه بينما اصيب الشاب محمد حرز
الله برصاصه في الراس منذ شهرين خلال
اقتحام قوات الاحتلال البلده القديمه فقد
شيع اهالي مدينه نابلس جثمان شهيدين بعد
مسيره غاضبه جابت شوارعها ممددينها بجرائم
الاحتلال